hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
unprecedented disaster concerns that
thousands of tons of methane is leaking
into the atmosphere from the damaged
Nordstrom gas pipelines
Labor's plans for a zero carbon
electricity system by 2030 we look at
whether that's realistic
and hurricane Ian is due to hit Florida
as a category 4 storm after wiping out
power supplies in Cuba
foreign
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis but let's start today in the
Baltic Sea where three leaks in two gas
pipelines are raising fears of a climate
disaster as greenhouse gases Escape into
the atmosphere neither of the Nord
stream pipelines were operational at the
time but both contained natural gas
which is largely composed of methane and
is the second biggest cause of climate
change behind carbon dioxide now the
European Union suspects the damage to
the pipelines was sabotaged and has
warned of retaliation for any attack on
Europe's energy Networks
now the Nord stream pipelines carry
natural gas from Russia all the way to
Germany now two leaks have been reported
on the Nord stream one Pipeline and one
on Nordstrom two or near the Danish
island of born home now Maritime
authorities have established a safety
zone of five nautical miles around the
island now this footage take a look at
this film by the Swedish Coast Guard
shows gas bubbling furiously on the
surface in a Baltic scene our Denmark's
prime minister says there's no doubt the
leaks are intentional and that several
explosions on the pipeline were observed
now our Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons joins us now Adam you know there
are a number of uncertainties with this
story but one thing is clear the
potential implications to The Climate
could be disastrous
yeah exactly there's an awful lot of not
knowns here we don't know precisely who
did this lots of people suspect it was
Russia we don't know why they did it I
don't know how they did it's going to be
hard to investigate investigate what we
do know is that a huge amount of methane
is bubbling up through the Baltic Sea
and coming out on the surface so another
fact we don't really know is how much
gas is in this Pipeline and and how it
reacts frankly there's no precedent for
this of a vast release of methane coming
to the surface so unknowns what was the
temperature of the gas in the pipe just
how much is in there what was the
pressure how is that changing of course
as it bubbles away and also how much of
that methane will be absorbed by
microbes on the way up to the surface
but all of that can't disguise the fact
that this is this is bad news methane is
the second most prevalent of the
greenhouse gases and and has over 20
years time frame has a much much greater
potency for warming the planet than as
uh than this carbon dioxide about 80
times higher so rough calculations I've
seen from scientists suggest that over
the course uh of a year this might be
equivalent to something like uh the
output of a million cars or the output
of a of a city the size of Helsinki in
terms of its climate impact so I mean
it's not world ending it is not utterly
catastrophic but this is very bad news
and I think the other thing this will do
is once again Focus attention on the
need to be energy sufficient in Europe
and to move away from these sort of
damaging fossil fuels and look further
at renewable energy
okay Adam thank you very much
now the labor leader Sakia stammer has
said he wants the UK to be a clean
energy superpower in his Leader's speech
to the labor conference yesterday he
announced plans to create a national
Energy company called Great British
energy and it would operate
independently but with a mandate to
invest in clean energy and emerging
Green Tech so labor says it will be a
clean generation company which will
harness the power of Britain's Sun wind
and waves and it would be given eight
billion pounds of initial funding
meaning it could potentially invest in
more experimental Tech like tidal power
and modular nuclear reactors well
Labor's overall ambition is for zero
carbon electricity system by 2030.
none of this will be easy it's not like
flicking a switch
it will mean tough battles on issues
like planning and regulation but when
the tour is naysay and carp remember
this
the road to Net Zero is no longer one of
stern or steer self-denial it's at the
heart of modern 21st century aspiration
Technologies turned everything on its
head
green and growth don't just go together
they're inseparable
but how realistic are Labor's plans well
I'm glad to say that Madeleine Radcliffe
is here now to discuss this I mean would
the tech be in place in time well it
certainly won't be easy it's certainly
very ambitious but the first thing to
say is this is actually an acceleration
of the current Target to get there by
2035 so we should already be on that
path but having said that it will be
very hard to go faster than we're
already going to double the amount of
solar and onshore wind we're getting
quadruple the amount of offshore uh wind
we're getting especially given how
volatile the current International
Energy Market is and there are several
really serious hurdles there because
it's not as simple as spend money get
some wind turbines in it the problem
sort it there'll be reforms to the
National Grid and to the energy Market
planning you know to get these turbines
these nuclear reactors in place that
will need changes to the planning laws
to get them there in fewer than 10 years
and of course it will rely on technology
that doesn't actually isn't proven to
work like carbon capture now spending on
that technology is crucial and that is
why the plan has been welcomed by
business groups and by
um environmental groups because this is
the first time we've seen this kind of
plan with the r d That's desperately
needed the spending on that r d so it
will get us there at some point it will
be a challenge to get there by 2030.
okay Maddie thank you very much for the
update on that
um let's take a look at some other
climate news for you today because
Jaguar Land Rover says it will train 29
000 employees to work on electric cars
that's in the next three years now the
company says it wants to make all jaguar
and Land Rover cars available in pure
electric form by the end of the decade
and at the moment around 80 percent of
its retailers around the world offer
electric vehicle servicing it's now
aiming for most servicing technicians to
have that sort of training this year
now fossil fuel companies have been
banned from recruiting students through
a university careers service for the
first time the new policy from birkbeck
University of London states its careers
service will not hold relationships of
any kind with oil gas or mining
companies now the decision follows a
campaign supported by the student-led
group people and planet to cut off
recruitment Pathways to fossil fuel
companies
Yorkshire water has warned its 5 million
customers the hose pipe ban in the
region could continue well into next
year the company imposed the ban in
August after Reservoir levels fell below
50 for the first time since 1995
Yorkshire water says that while there
has been a slight reduction in the
demand average levels at the Region's
reservoirs have dropped even more to 35
percent
now hurricane ear has strengthened into
an extremely dangerous category for
storm as it heads towards the U.S state
of Florida now the National Hurricane
Center says a life-threatening storm
surge is now expected along the west
coast of Florida and the Florida Keys
area with the possibility of 160 mile
per hour winds well this comes after the
hurricane tore through Cuba and knocked
out the country's entire electricity
grid the storm left 11 million people
across the island without power and
devastated some of the country's most
important tobacco Farms but let's take a
look at some live pictures shall we in
Florida right now from The Not So aptly
named Sunshine Skyway near Tampa Bay
which has now been shut because of high
winds and in the last few minutes the
President Joe Biden has said the storm
is incredibly dangerous and people
should obey all the warnings just look
at that well our U.S correspondent
Martha Kellner sent this update we're
still a few hours away from Hurricane
Ian making landfall but when it's
located
[Applause]
just how much the winds have already
picked up lashing rain there are areas
that are already fluttered and it's
important to note that while the wind
speed is expected to be well in excess
of 100 miles per hour it's the sheer
force of the water that people are
seeing most in some coastal areas a
worst case scenario projects the storm
surge so that's the wall of water to be
between 12 and 18 feet for some of the
coastal areas in this part of western
Florida that would be utterly
devastating and that's why authorities
have made a mandatory evacuation order
for 2.5 million residents in these areas
projected to be worse affected but
Floridians have seen these storms before
and in a number of them in a minority
there is some complacency so some people
have stayed at home doing what they can
to protect their property that's
involved lining the areas the entrances
for their properties with some some bags
um putting boards up on the Windows
we've just been down to the marina area
of Fort Myers and there are some people
who have chosen to remain on their boats
to incredible though that might seem in
this wind we saw one elderly gentleman
staying in his car keeping a watchful
eye on his boat people fear the
potential life-changing impact of what
now will certainly be a catastrophic
event a category four storm one of the
most powerful ever to approach landfall
in the US expected to hit in the next
few hours
okay and finally could this be the
future of Aviation take a look a U.S
company has conducted its first electric
plane test flights flying a
battery-powered plane for eight minutes
over Washington State now the plane is
powered by 21 and a half thousand
battery sales and could carry about nine
passengers as it stands the company aims
to deliver electric passenger and cargo
planes by 2027.